اي الايام هي الاخطر على قلوب البشر نوبات
القلبيه الخطيره شائعه اكثر تخيلوا ايام
الاثنين بالمقارنه مع باقي ايام الاسبوع
يعني في بدايه الاسبوع بالنسبه طيب دراسه
جديده ايرلنديه
رصدت ارتفاعا بنسبه ثلاثه عشره بالمئه في
النوبات القلبيه في بدايه اسبوع العمل
بالضبط البيانات وجدت ان اخطر حالات
النوبات القلبيه والمعروفه باسم احتشاء
عدد عضله القلب
وبحسب تتبع للحالات ما بين عامي 2013
و2018 اخطر الحالات سجلت ايام الاثنين وحل
يوم الاحد في المرتبه الثانيه طبعا هناك
من يربط هذه الارقام بالتوتر المرتبط
بالعوده الى العمل بدايه كل اسبوع شو احنا
نبلش يوم الاحد
الحمد لله طيب
نوباتنا تصير بالضبط
سلامه قلوبكم دائما لا تقولون صباح
العربيه جاب هذه الدراسه طيب لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات